okay let's go to the batteries here okay
the battery uh is ready to power the
world okay
the flow of batteries is currently
dominated by asian countries and
companies nearly 65
of lithium ion batteries come from china
let me repeat that one more time
65 of lithium ion batteries
come from china by comparison no single
country produces more than 20
of global crude oil output 65
this is an absolute monopoly coming out
of asia
rechargeable lithium ion batteries were
first commercially used and held hand
camcorders in 1991 laptops soon followed
a decade later batteries enabled the
rise of tech titans such as apple link
by
powering smartphones and wearable
devices then made their way into
electric vehicles
the basic technology throughout remain
pretty much the same lithium ions move
through a liquid from the cathode to the
anode and back again
this however was just the beginning
after decade of rapidly falling costs
the battery has reached
a tipping point no longer just for
consumer products it's poised to
transform the way
the world uses power the gains are less
likely are likely to continue electrical
vehicles
vehicles are currently the main source
of demand for battery cells as demand
grows
and the costs fall further batteries
will become even more disruptive across
industries battery industries score to
win at general motors
company would set it hope to phase out
gasoline and diesel-powered vehicles
from its showrooms worldwide by 2035.
the first commercially available etc
okay so kai tell us what's going on with
this batteries
and why should we be paying attention to
this um so obviously
just looking at the 65 percent it's a
shocking number that that's coming out
of g yes
so first thing i looked at then was
which countries have the biggest lithium
iron ores or the mines right
surprisingly
who would who would we think is on top
china exactly okay however china is
not on top on top you have bolivia
it's number one you have argentina's
number two you have chile as number
three by the way those are some of the
three worst
countries to do business with yeah so
you looked at it on that list they're
like largely undeveloped yes they're not
doing anything well argentina changed it
they used to be up here yeah they went a
different direction three south american
companies
it was deemed as too risky for financial
investment so bolivia argentina chile
continue
fourth one no none other than usa how
many
iron uh how many lithuania lithium ores
do we have open
no one in nevada guess who hinted
at creating a second one in nevada who
none other than elon musk because he
wanted independence
not having to rely on others um however
number five is australia and then number
six
is china china has five point
uh 4.5 billion tons bolivia has 21
million tons or they're both in millions
uh however
the thing that is different is out of
all the countries china is the one
that's pulling the most
iron ore or lithium ore out of the
ground
other countries aren't so that's a
concerning however
another part of it is australia they
export uh they exported 1.9 billion
dollars
of uh lithium right most of it
went into none other than china
exactly okay so they're getting why
should we be concerned about this why
should we be concerned about the concern
about it is in some ways just that
they're they're they're
marketalizing they have the control of
it obviously we saw now with uh
the disruption in supply chains that we
have
the struggle of getting the chips that
we needed
and self-sustaining kind of how we're
building things
another part of it is with the increase
in the electrical
vehicles and the batteries i mean
batteries moving forward are just going
to be more important
the reason oil has been a strong
commodity as long as it has
is it's easy to transport you put it in
a tanker
you you drive it wherever you want and
you drop it off it has the same
energy value and kind of efficiency
wherever it is
gas you can send it in in pipes and it
stays the same
batteries or especially electricity you
know the high voltage ones
they lose a lot of power when you're
sending the electricity so what you send
from a if you're saying 100
you're not receiving 100 on the other
end so batteries are the closest way we
can do that
and that is why if you look at tesla
the biggest thing they're doing is
battery development and figuring out how
you can store the energy
transport the energy and get the most
out of it later on
so that's i mean the future is going to
be in batteries because we need to store
the energy we
need to figure out how to do it as
efficiently as possible and obviously
china is leading the front on that end
the future is in batteries you just said
let me me let me let me tee you up and
tee you up
you know how they say you know you only
remember you know
20 of what you see and 10 of what you
hear and
whatever the thing is but people
remember how you make them
feel how should people feel about this
battery stuff because i don't speak
robot i don't speak battery
i'm hearing like you know i'm hearing a
lot of math guys
yeah exactly for a mathematician i'm
hearing a lot of batteries i'm hearing a
lot of lithium i'm hearing a lot of
mining how should we feel about this i
mean there's
a there's a reason for concern
especially if if things are being more
kind of split and uh companies
aren't being able to get as much from
china it's it's it's very easy
adam here's how you gotta look at it so
what perc
what percentage of the cars you guys got
to turn off your thing because i keep
hearing your audio you turn off your
speaker because i keep hearing
uh typing i hear it okay thank you so
what percentage of cars are gonna be
uh uh battery driven cars in the next 10
years
a lot more than they are today give me
that 50 percent was projected by 2040.
20 40 50 percent in the u.s 50 no 50 of
cars worldwide yes
okay so 50 50 worldwide by 2040. and if
will ferrell has it's gonna happen
sooner than that if it's up to welfare
boy i know you guys are having a service
debate so but watch this
so if that's the case by 2040 yeah
who has control electric cars
okay so you remember when people said
why is elon musk shaking hands in in
china
why is he doing by the way his business
is growing in china there's uh
he's he's done a great job being a
diplomat working with other countries
trying to get that part going
yeah however everything going in germany
as well however let me tell you
what this means in a whole different way
if this is the case
and we need you know import export
guess what country cannot have sanctions
with u.s guess what country cannot have
any kind of sanctions china
china so those sanctions need to be
lifted because
businesses behind closed doors such as
gm the tesla's everybody else gonna be
like listen
we need china they own 65 percent of it
you're shutting them down you're hurting
our business
we want to create costs you're
increasing the cost
you got to open it up so look how it's
it's like the story okay let me tell you
the story so
um yesterday i was on a podcast girl
asked me and said
you know the the podcast was called uh
women something about women what was it
uh women in business women in business
terms something like that so she said
what what can women do to be you know
more uh you know successful in business
i'm like look i i can tell you from my
perspective on what any person can do
man or woman let me tell you a story and
this is exactly what china did so there
was a king
this king has a daughter he wants his
daughter
to marry a prince but this daughter
ends up dating a local
uh uh guy and they get together and he
finds out about it
when the news gets back to the king that
the daughter ended up hooking up with a
local guy
the king sends his troops to go do what
kill the guy
so they go get the guy and everybody
tells him listen man you're about to get
killed
his people are coming after you're going
to die today they're going to kill you
they want to make a public example out
of you
this guy panics he's like oh my gosh
what are you talking about this is crazy
he says well you got to figure something
i do run away i can't run away that's
where i have everything
he said uh i have a plan it's okay
so he on the side was a psychic
okay where he would like do your what do
you call it like readings and all this
other stuff
so they come to kill him and says look
before you kill me i have some news that
i have to tell the king
the king has to know this and it's bad
for him but he has to know this as a
psychic i have a vision
and i've seen it i saw it yesterday he
has to hear the news
so what do they do well the king hey we
have to take you he wants to say this so
the king says come on and before we kill
him i want to see what you have to say
he goes to the king and the king says
what do you have to say he says
well i had a vision i was reading and
seeing where you were at and what's
going to happen with your future
my prediction is you're going to die day
after i die okay
so the king says what do you mean he
says whatever day i die
you die the next day so the king who's
an extremely superstitious guy says dude
we can't kill this guy
we got to make sure we give him the best
life so the king brings him in
hasn't married the daughter okay and he
says take care of him what ends up
happening
the guy outlives the king and the king
ends up dying
in this situation china's the psychic
[Laughter]
china has made it impossible to sanction
them
china has made it a monopoly to say i
dare you to sanction us listen what are
you talking about sanctioning us
you're going to need us long term and
they're sitting there saying
you taught us capitalism we brought it
in everything you did you allowed us to
take all your trade secrets we're
already so competitive it's so hard for
listen we're the number one you know
we're going to win we're the future of
the world we're the future of the
capitals and we're the future of
business every innovation is going to
come from us because
you taught us but it's too late so this
entire battery game is a monopoly game
for china
congratulations china you have won the
game because that's the direction the
world is going
big victory for asian countries
imagine you're playing a football game
the score is 65 to nothing
third quarter second quarter you're
gonna have to do a buffalo bill's
comeback
yeah we got to get tom brady on the
scene brady exactly
matt ryan so that's kind of where they
have such a
long big lead who's going to come in and
try to compete with these guys
because if you think of it also as the
market obviously the market cap for
batteries and the need for it's gonna
expand but they're just gonna grow with
it
so the world is going moving towards
batteries and china's already there
saying come to my wheelhouse baby
what is this controlled by what is that
controlled by what's phone controlled by
what's the watch controlled by you're
saying
batteries are controlling big tech
batteries i mean they're the energy of
it
guys we learned something today here on
the bet david podcast batteries
but i think that's where investment has
to play a large role i mean you talked
about it's not like
they're the only ones with actual
lithium but which is the good thing
that's the great
thing it's a great thing but you have to
invest in that and we're talk like right
now we're talking about 1.9 trillion
dollar
you know uh relief bill it's not like we
don't have money
it's how we choose to spend our money
and we have to choose to invest
in our future and we're not doing that
when are you running for mayor i mean it
doesn't all should wear those glasses
more
that message the way you just said it i
i knew some i'm coming for you buddy
yeah ice cube for president paula
scarcita and i endorse this
message just say that once paul say say
it once i'm paula skarska and i endorse
this message beautiful i i like
it so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye